okay so I'd like to welcome our next
speaker dr. ed Boyden so here's the Y
Eva tan professor in neuro technology at
MIT
leader of the synthetic neurobiology
group at MIT Media Lab co-director of
neuro biological engineering and he's
been an investigator at the McGovern
Institute since 2006 he conducted his
PhD work at Stanford during which he
invented and developed a groundbreaking
technology optogenetics which has
revolutionized neuroscience with Bob
mentioned earlier it's received many
awards and accolades and was selected as
for prestigious HHMI investigator
position recently ed is developing tools
that image and control the brain and
applying them to solve entire brain
circuits this ambitious goal is
exemplified in his continuously
innovative and highly collaborative
research and creativity and he has the
intriguing title from structure to
function optical tools for analyzing the
complexity of the brain great honor to
be here today and remembering McGovern
and along with Laurie co-founded this
fantastic Institute its spend
transformative to our group to be part
of it and to be collaborating with such
amazing people because at the end it is
all about the people and to work with
great colleagues collaborators and and
and friends so I direct a group here at
the McGovern and also at the MIT Media
Lab which is focused on trying to figure
out how to link the underlying building
blocks of the brain to the emergent
dynamics and functions and a lot of our
work has been technological in nature
but we're also finding ourselves
increasingly tackling scientific
questions as well as the tools get
better and better at this point
I would say that the overarching
question that that gets me out of bed in
the morning is this question of linking
structure and function could we make
maps of the brain the wiring but not
just the wires the molecules along the
wires
at the connections between brain cells
and measure behavior and dynamics and
perturb behavior and dynamics in a way
that lets us connect these levels of
description my dream is someday that we
could let's say going from bottom to top
here watch neural activity throughout
neural circuits with enough precision
spatial and temporal that when we
perturb them we can the middle
controlling topic there be able to test
a causal way what patterns are important
and then finally the the top part there
in the blue
not the molecules and wires and
synthesize these datasets in two models
of how brain circuits operate my dream
is that these models could be someday
biologically realistic and human
understandable of course there's no
guarantee of the latter but we are
optimists in science and up till now
we've been focusing on tools that really
obey to sort of general design
principles and it helps to sort of
discuss why the brain is so complicated
and there's many many reasons but one of
the issues of course is there's a
tremendous differing in spatial scales
that we deal with so brain cells are
enormous in the human brain and they're
centimetres a spatial extent or if you
count going down the spinal cord a meter
in length and yet if you care about the
wires in the brain axons and dendrites
or the connections like synapses those
are nano scale in dimension and
chock-full of nano scale building blocks
biomolecules of which they're somewhere
between tens of thousands and millions
we actually don't know the exact number
so how can you see and ideally control
biological building blocks and functions
across these incredible spatial scales
this represents a real challenge and a
lot of the older tools that were
developed for smaller ranges of scales
in biology don't generalize well to the
brain and the other issue is time so
similarly to the spatial scales the
temporal scales that we deal with are
really daunting if you care about
learning or neurological disease or
development or aging these are
timescales of years or decades we're
talking about I get the quantum building
blocks of neural computations are
electrical pulses within brain cells and
chemical exchanges between brain cells
that lasts a thousandth of a second so
one of our you know day jobs in our
group is building tools that help
neuroscientists across these spatial and
temporal de menthe
so today I'll tell you three short
stories as an end with a view towards
the future about how we hope to develop
and refine the approach to neuroscience
that really allows us to cross these
spatial and temporal scales in an
ideally an integrative fashion these
tools should work together well and be
used together to coherently answer
scientific questions so let's start with
mapping how do you map the molecules
throughout brain cells and the brain
cells throughout entire circuits so
around the time we began this project
there were many people working on ways
to image brain circuits for example
electronic Kostka P gives you incredible
resolution but struggles to give you
multiplex molecular information from
inside the brain and many people have
been working on super resolution
microscopy in fact a few of the
inventors even won the Nobel Prize in
Chemistry a couple years back but these
tend to be slow and difficult to apply
to extended 3d objects so in our group
starting with to then best in its fate
Chanderpaul Tilburg and now about half
my group work said this decided what if
we do the opposite of what people have
been doing for hundreds of years rather
than zoom in onto a piece of a cell or a
piece of a tissue let's do the opposite
and blow it up then you can use really
inexpensive optics scalable optics to do
3d imaging with nanoscale precision
because if we blow up the brain in an
even fashion that takes care of the
magnification for you so after that you
have many ways of doing this we converge
upon the following idea what if you
could actually take a swellable polymer
like the stuff you find in baby diapers
sodium polyacrylate and weave a
spiderweb like mesh so densest so evenly
around between the biomolecules of the
cells of the brain that you can actually
pull the biomolecules apart so that a
brain cell like the one on the left side
of this cartoon shown in gold would turn
into something like the one on the right
a constellation of biomolecules hovering
in space like stars in a constellation
in the sky but anchored to the polymer
and expanded evenly from each other now
to do that we had to invent several new
kinds of chemistry's or borrow
chemistry's from the field of chemical
engineering one of the things we had to
borrow were anchoring molecules so this
cartoon the brownish blobs are proteins
and we have now developed anchoring
molecules or found ones that are
commercially available that will bind to
proteins
dna/rna and in our own group we have
unpublished work where we're working on
lipids and also with Laura Keesling
groups here at MIT on sugars so the
purplish blob here is an anchoring
molecule that binds the protein and
equips it with a handle next we had to
set the size a polymer mesh throughout
the specimen and to do that we can soak
the specimen in a solution of monomers
shown as a little white spheres and they
self assemble into long polymeric chains
shown as assemblages of the white
spheres and when these growing chains
encounter a handle though for a covalent
bond so ever think about it this white
polymer is a swellable polymer so just
as the stuff in baby diapers if you add
water it should swell and provide force
to the handles which will then pull the
biomolecules apart but there's one last
thing we had to figure out and that's
how to soften the tissue because the
molecules are very happy where they are
and so we use detergents enzymes and or
heat to loosen up or sometimes even
destroy if we don't care about it
biomolecules and then the water will
cause the sodium polyacrylate that may
be direct material to swell but now the
biomolecules will come along for the
ride so we first reported the discovery
that we could evenly swell a biological
specimen back in 2015 the swelling is
not perfect there's a few percent of
distortion over linked scales of tens to
hundreds of microns but for the vast
majority of biological and medical
questions that's okay
and we are working to make it even more
even for the subset of questions that
require more precision and panel B is a
piece of the mouse brain and in panel C
on the right is the same piece of mouse
brain tissue about a day and a half
later when we have blown it up by about
a hundred times in volume about four and
a half times in each direction and then
the upper left is a cartoon and of the
dense polymer mesh we know from previous
literature from chemical engineering
going back many decades that the spacing
between polymer threads is really tiny
maybe as low as one to two nanometers
around the size of a biomolecule or even
smaller so when the power mesh swells
like in the little schematic of the
lower left we can anticipate with good
reason that the design of our chemistry
will allow us to get precision down to
some number of nanometers and we and
many others now have validate the
resolution down to around 20 nanometers
below that the jury's still out and will
work
refine it further and so stay tuned so
here's a little movie of a piece of
mouse brain tissue that's been flipper
eyes and now we're adding water to
expand it the movie sped up by about a
factor of 50 but I hope you can see
that's growing right before your very
eyes and it's a pretty fast process the
whole process takes about an hour let's
say and it's pretty easy to learn
we've now taught well over 300 research
groups how to do it and also show you
later it's being applied to all sorts of
stuff now as I mentioned the expansion
is not perfectly even we've done a lot
of validation to try to see how accurate
it is the polar expansion process is
pretty good because of its design that I
told you about but also because we
validated it at a wide variety of
tissues for a wide variety of species
and so but we do find by do comparing
post expansion images to pre expansion
images taken with classical super
resolution methods they're slowed
expensive but they work well over small
volumes is that we actually are getting
pretty good low distortion levels so
here's an example of actually some data
from our very first paper on it the left
column shows us zooming in into a 5-1
yfp mouse that will ping and colleagues
made many years ago and on the right is
the same zoom in after we expand and I
hope that you can see the color codes
explained on the Left we have anti
bassoon in blue a presynaptic protein
and anti hover in magenta pushed optic
protein as we zoom in intuitively into
the white squares we eventually hit the
resolution limit of the microscope this
light has a finite size or wavelength
and you can't see much smaller than but
the right-hand side we can go all the
way into even parts of synapses so here
is blue and magenta the postsynaptic is
gives you the presynaptic and
postsynaptic densities that aren't on
either side of synaptic cleft and at the
upper right if we measure the distance
between the centroids of these two
regions we get the same answer that
using storm microscopy is always wrong
this group found many years ago of the
distance between these but now we can
get this kind of information on regular
old confocal microscopes which are
practically ubiquitous in neuroscience
now one fun thing about this process as
a byproduct of the expansion process is
that you end up with something that's
like 99% water because you're soaked it
in water the water has drifted into by
osmosis and it swells it so you get
something
that as you can see on the left-hand
side ends up pretty much perfectly clear
so in panel a is a piece of a mouse
brain and the upper left and in the
lower left in panel B is the same piece
of mouse brain tissue and it's
completely transparent and refractive
index and modernized now why is that
interesting well as we found and also as
Wasi would you join her team and many
other people helped us in the study if
you expand something that it becomes
transparent you can then shine light
from the side let's say I take a picture
from the top so called white sheet
imaging and then you can go much much
faster than before in fact working with
Eric Betts aghhh
one of the winners of the Nobel Prize
for his work at super resolution and now
a convert to expansion recalls can be
done happy to say we actually
collaborated to use one of his light
sheet microscopy a lattice light sheet
microscope to image expanded brain
tissue so in a collaboration triply
spearheaded by Ray Gaucho asano and Goku
a potter EULA working across many of our
groups showed in the lower right we
expanded brains labeled them with
antibodies that bore fluorophores and
then by using one of these clever
lattice light sheet microscopy that
Eric's group invented we found that we
could image almost a thousand times
faster than a comparable resolution
previous super resolution method it's
only a matter of engineering we think to
go much much faster so we're talking
about many many orders of magnitude
improvement in our ability to rapidly
scan brain circuits so shown here on the
upper right let's say our mitochondria
in purple and lysosomes in yellow
stained with antibodies here we are
imaging the thickness of the mouse
cortex with layer one on the right and
layer six on the left same color code as
shown before and the in sets are zoomed
in in the bottom so rather than go
through all the panels one by one I'll
show you just a movie here where in
yellow are those famous by one yfp mice
glowing with yellow frozen protein and
then blue and magenta is the same color
code as before showing pre and
postsynaptic sides of synapses that's
not a long movie so I think I'm gonna
skip to a part in the middle where you
kind of zoom in a bit and you can start
to really see the ability to look at
individual synapses but not lose sight
of the overall architecture of the
neuron and that's really I think at the
soul of this question that I posed in
the beginning how do you cross spatial
scales which are in varying this tension
where you don't want to lose sight to
the nanoscale building blocks like
synapses
you sure also don't want to lose sight
of the architecture of neural circuitry
as well Eric being a Jew nearly research
campus we of course had to do some work
on Drosophila whoops let's see if this
movie works this is one my favorite
movies so if you actually will fly
through the fly brain here we have
dopamine neurons expressing fluorophores
that's what you see shown here in the
outlines of neurons and of course doping
is so important for so many things but
if you could image all the neurons in an
entire brain and Link those neural
architectures to the connections and the
molecules that are in those neurons were
very excited now that whole brain
imaging of circuitry and building blocks
of circuitry might now be within grasp
and on that note one of the most
immediate applications of this kind of
work is to look at the wiring of the
brain this is some work that we
published a couple years ago
collaborative dhawan Chi one of the
recent pioneers of Brainbow techniques
when he was working with Jeff Lichtman
and now in his own group at Michigan and
what you can see here in the lower panel
is a piece of mouse hippocampus with
rainbow namely fluorophores genetically
encoded that are virally expressed in
random combinations so the blue cell and
the green cell express different
fluorophores maybe some of the Aqua and
blue-green cells Express combinations
and at the top middle panel you can see
what it looks like when you zoom in
beautiful colors but it's very hard to
see individual axons especially when
they're close by but if the upper-right
is what you get after you expand so of
course the image is much bigger but we
shrank it to fit on the slide and I'll
just use my mouse pointer to highlight
this little green banana shape here but
before it before you expand it's really
hard to know what we're looking at here
we are in the highlights of the mouse of
a campus but after you expand you can
cleanly resolve individual exercise even
in this very dense narrow play rich
arena so we're very excited now about
scaling up our color coding and also
scaling up our expansion factors as I'll
show you in a second
importantly you can look at things other
than proteins so so far everything I've
shown you is a protein but you can also
enter the work that eh and AHS Wasi and
collaboration with Arjun Raj alison coat
and Argent's group and others we worked
on together we developed anchors that
bind to RNA so now you can bind
jeans have already form expand them and
then do fluorescent in situ
hybridisation afterwards and just to
focus on the right-hand side of the
slide we're looking here at classic
dendritic ly localized rnaseq M kinase 2
and now we can see them along dendrites
through even in synaptic spines which is
very difficult to do it Ted brain
tissues now this is joint knowledge
anyway the first nanoscale resolution
imaging of single RNA molecules deep in
in intact brain circuits if you could
expand rnase from each other maybe you
can also use the room that you make
around the molecules that have been D
crowded to run interesting biochemistry
as we just submitted a paper which was
not Senate for review where we adapted
the George church's labs in situ
sequencing chemistry's to work in
expanded brains so their group had to my
knowledge the only untargeted in sintra
sequencing method you don't want to
hybridize to an entire it used for a
sequence everything and find out what
cells are expressing unlike other ways
of sequencing where you grind up the
tissue and extract the RNA they're
basically running sequencing chemistry
is right inside cells now when we try to
anticipate well so what we decided this
is work triply spreaded by shahara law
and Dan Goodwin and Fei Chen along with
great contributions from evan doherty
and george's group if we anchor the rnas
and then expanded the way for each other
we could then amplify the resulting see
DNA's after reverse transcription and
then run sequencing so when you're on
sequencing you're basically copying the
nucleic acid and as you copy it you add
fluorescent nucleotides and so what
happens is over many rounds of
sequencing you will get these individual
gene expression products located
different points of the cell to blink
out their identity and that's exactly
what we got so the low-riding panel you
can see 20 rounds of sequencing going
down these columns and each of these
colors blue green magenta red correspond
to letters of the genome so what does
that mean well again there's lots of
ways of doing targeted analysis of
transcripts in tissues but our method is
to my knowledge is first method doing
untargeted analysis of transcripts and
intact issues so what we can do here is
take a piece of brain here we are in the
mouse hippocampus again expand it and
then look at the identity and location
of expressed RNAs in the circuitry even
in the context of the shapes of the
cells the morphologies of cells and
maybe somebody sue in the connections
so what does it mean to be untargeted it
means we don't have to have a hypothesis
about what genes are expressed so we can
look at for example things like
different transcription factors which
you know of course do their business in
the nucleus but you can find them
hanging out in the dendrites far away
from the nucleus intron containing
transcripts you know neurons have one
nucleus but thousands of synapses people
have found evidence that neurons do
splicing later after the ever RNAs are
shipped out of the nucleus but here now
we can actually pinpoint where they are
that's what's shown in magenta and all
sorts of other things as well structural
RNAs and so on and so forth
sir very excited now if you put two and
two together that we could use color
codes I could show you earlier to get
the maps of the wiring and then
untargeted such a sequence say and they
got the maps of gene expression and
integrate these all into a cohesive
strategy for mapping out the building
blocks and wires in neural circuits now
to do it with very fine resolution you
might need to expend more than the
hundred x volumetric expansion that I
showed you and so when JB Chang was a
postdoc in our group we decided to try
to mattify things bigger how do you do
that well you can take a piece of braid
and polymerize it and expand it like I
showed you earlier and then could form a
second polymer shown in this cartoon in
orange and in the space open up by the
first and expand it again so it's got my
PCR but for space you do an exponential
amplification in space with a linear
number of steps and it works so in the
upper left here just to pick one example
I know it's a crowded slide before I
showed you Homer and bassoon which we
often use as there's a ruler and before
you saw those two protein densities
touching after double expansion which
which gives you a 20x linear expansion
there's now a gap between them and sure
enough if you antibodies stained with an
antibody and Skloot of a receptors which
of course they are the synaptic cleft
you can see them in between the pre and
postsynaptic densities as something
similar holds for inhibitory synapses
going back to brain Bo and the upper
left you can see an unexpected piece of
brain tissue and the upper right after
you spend once so you can see many of
the wires but some things like spine
necks are still hard to resolve and then
in the lower left is double expansion
and I hope you can see here that the
image looks kind of punctate kind of
speckly and so we really think now
they're getting down to nearly single
molecule detection although we have not
yet proven that we have single molecule
resolution
alluded to earlier we still have to
validate under the 20 nanometer length
scale Yong Jie Zhao Octavia Bakr working
between my group and several pathology
groups astrid why institution and debug
we got it working in human tissues so
this has now been applied to a wide
variety of human tissues including human
brain tissue I think I'll end this part
of the talk just by pointing out that
many many people have started using
Spanish and in many many contexts we had
a great collaboration with Ann Graybiel
shown in the upper left to look at
striatal circuitry it's been applied to
bacteria and the upper left human brain
in the upper middle our group has been
working even with several other groups
on elegans and Laura left work spared it
by Ju in our group with help of many
others and all the protocols are on our
website expansion I cost me org and
we're happy to help teach usage of the
tools and to explore how to improve them
if you give us feedback as well so
that's the first story I want to tell
you about and in the last third of the
time remaining I really want to talk
about live imaging and live control so
of course expansion only works on
preserved things we do have some ideas
about I try to preserve some living
functions and expanded things but of
course everything's anchored in place or
diffusion won't work and it's a really
weird environment so in terms of live
control imaging of course we've been
working for many years on optogenetics
where we use bytes to control neurons
that Express a genetically encoded
construct why light low and Karl Deutsch
Roth and I started brainstorming out
this we decided just to go through all
the laws of physics mad magnetism
ultrasound etc and decided light would
be great if you could pull it off
because you could aim it at things and
also it's as fast as anything ever gets
so you could actually keep up with the
high speed of activity of the brain
many many times over and then you have
to get light into the brain as you've
already seen in earlier talks this is
something that is not so hard to do if
you use a device that conveys light into
the brain instead of an electrode which
of course has been used for many many
years so that the question becomes how
to be brain cell sensitive to light well
it turns out the natural world has
evolved the class of molecules that does
just that so over the last half-century
many people have characterized light
driven ion pumps and channels that
convert light into electrical gradients
so the upper left is an images of salty
water in the edge of a body of water and
the lower left is
structure the crystal structure of a
pigment that's found in a microbe the
lizards of salty water and this pigment
doesn't just do nothing
it converts light into an ionic gradient
by pumping protons from one side of the
membrane to the other that was called
bacteriorhodopsin later several groups
found hailer rhodopsins like driven
chloride pumps that do something similar
but for chloride these are pumps that
convert light into electrical gradients
so they're thought to be serving a photo
energetic role and a store energy in
chemical form and then around the turn
of the millennium light driven ion
channels are found being channels of
course they don't store energy but they
can be used to tell single-celled algae
where to go and bodies of water
Sarika long story short what we found
over the years is his work that's been
led by many people in the group
including brian Xiao Han Amy Chuang
Nathan Kopecky and others is that
members of all three of these classes of
light driven ion pump and channel can be
found that are safe effective and fast
enough to work in delicate mammalian
neurons and this is a lot of serendipity
we didn't have to engineer these
molecules almost at all and amazingly I
forgot to mention this but these
molecules have a chemical cofactor
called all trans retinal and amazingly
we don't have to add that chemical these
proteins worked out of the box in intact
mammalian brain circuits so a lot of
luck lined up here anyway with light
driven proton pumps and light driven
chloride pumps we found that we could
either bring positive charge out of
neurons or negative charge into neurons
which allow us to shut down neural
activity and with light driven ion
channels which the earliest of which
would let positive charge into brain
cells we could activate them and more
recently people have found and made
versions that also will let negative
charge into cells and he's come in
different colors the colors shown here
green orange and blue are the colors
originally used to drive these but in
recent years with Aimee and Nathan's PhD
theses we've been trying to find
molecules that are sensitive to red
light because the red light of course
goes deep for the body of an green line
this is a green laser pointer but if I
shot on my finger you can't even see it
I've got a red laser pointer I could do
a the opposite where you would see my
finger glowing
so where's the frontier here well we
have a very close collaboration of
Valentino Milanese crew to try to push
these molecules to the point of
single-cell resolution
up till now most groups have been using
optogenetics to activate or silenced
populations of neurons turning on an
office set in synchrony with each other
and that's great
much we've learned about neurons by
doing so but would it be great to be
able to activate neurons individually
this is even two identical or very close
in phenotype cells nearby to each other
could have different neural codes so our
Suresh in my group and to meet you today
say Anna Blair isn't fini and
Valentina's group worked together to use
Valentina's holographic microscope
projection systems they make interesting
patterns of life like the one you see at
the bottom here could you use these to
do good single-cell resolution control
so to do that we had to find a way to
target the expression of these microbial
opsins as they're known to just the cell
bodies this is not our idea many groups
have done this before like MacLean
Bolton's Jawa pons and Frank riblets but
it solves a problem that is tricky which
is namely if you use microscopes that
like valentina is to aim light at a
single cell shown here in the dotted
lines you activate the straight cells
nearby whose axons and dendrites
dendrites happen to wander around the
cell of interest and you can target to
the cell body though that aiming light
at that cell body will be enough to
clean up the background because the
other axons and dendrites will be bare
so now a group we started wondering you
know MacLean and Java and Frank had
targeted one of the older options called
channelrhodopsin-2 to the cell body what
if we tried to actually do a dual search
in genomic space as well as in
engineering space to find a molecule
that was an order of magnitude better
now it turns out that Nathan when he was
discovering a red light activator call
it that we call crimson many years ago
he also found a molecule that we called
CEO Steve Chara which has 10 times
bigger photo currents than the chatter
Dobson - that was put into neurons by
Carl dice Roth and myself many years ago
and if we'd known it was gonna be a cool
molecule we would have called it
something more interesting than Co CHR
but we weren't that visionary
anyway or a postdoc in the groove found
a peptide from a KT receptor that we
fused to C or CHR and this is in the
mouse cortex you can see that the
background fluorescence indicated by GFP
fused to the
and really gets cleaned up when we have
this peptide from Kennett receptor to
attach to it and so now when we do
holographic stimulation using a
Valentina's holographic projector we
could actually then get activation of
single cells without activating straight
cells so if you patch a cell at the scan
around with the regular Co CHR a third
of the time we get straight activation
but with the soma targeted version we
almost never gets to activation because
Co CHR is so powerful we can use brief
bright pulses of light and get some
little second jitter or temporal error
of the action potential since the update
I wanted to share with you on the
optogenetic control front and I just
wanted to emphasize one thing which was
the enormous amount of serendipity that
occurred we were lucky to get molecules
they were safe fast and effective
basically right out of the box and they
also were able to use the all trans
retinal that for some reason is found
actually in the mammalian brain but
without the opposite in terms of imaging
neural activity there were not so lucky
the natural world has not provided us
through evolution molecules that will
light up neurons when they're active and
so we have to work hard to make them and
so here OPI eviction Erica young who are
currently and former postdocs in the
group along with many collaborators
shown in the lower right we decided if
they chose uh can evolve these for us
we're gonna evolve these things
ourselves in the laboratory now directed
evolution is a very hot topic won the
Nobel Prize in Chemistry recently but
doing it in an automated way would
really help to optimize these difficult
to optimize molecules like fluorescent
indicators of neural activity and we
chose to build voltage indicators
because then we could really get very
fine scaled information in terms of the
temporal and amplitude properties of
synaptic events action potentials and
sub-threshold oscillations so what you
see here is basically a robotic
scientist for building the top row just
shows how we take a gene of interest in
this case we started with Adam Cohen
squeeze our two molecule a candidate for
us at voltage indicator that works well
at cultured cells but it is dim and
poorly localized in vivo and then the
bottom part of the slide you can see how
we picked the cells we select four cells
that have mutants of clays are two that
are bright fast and photo stable and
well localized at the membrane and then
we use a robotic
to pick out the cells and therefore the
mutants that have interesting properties
and so these are very very massive
directed evolution screen so we did them
all of a million cells too because we
didn't want to optimize the genes for
better working in let's say bacteria we
want them to work in neurons and so the
pipeline you can see on the left and on
the right you can see how important it
is to screen along multiple quality axes
at once if you screen for localization
you can improve localization but
brightness might not get better you can
screen for brightness you might get
something brighter but it might not be
better localized and if you screen for
both you can optimize along both axes at
once so this is kind of crowded slide
but let me just summarize a few key
points and the upper left we get really
good localization compared to the parent
quasar to its somewhat brighter as well
and the lower right we've improved the
photo stability in the lower left it's
still quite fast quasar 2 is a very fast
molecule and in the upper right up here
it is good change in fluorescence or
dynamic range and good signal to noise
so what that means is this is from a
Tartar prior to seventies group you can
use this molecule that we call our con 1
where you shine red light on it and it
flores's with far red light 660
nanometers and redder and you can get
for example the monitoring of synaptic
events so here we're stimulating or
they're stimulating I should say in
layer 5/6 of the mouse cortex and
patching an imaging layer 2 3 and the
lower left-hand corner you can see in
black the patch clamp snapped ik events
that are measured and a magenta is what
you see on a regular old one photon
microscope image without averaging their
works in other species since we also
have time just to show some data from
larval zebrafish where again you can see
spiking events acept and synaptic events
shown in magenta where my mouse is
pointing c elegans working with C Flavel
here at MIT we could also see synaptic
events between two defined neurons so
can we monitor the connections between
cells in real time during behavior and
most recently claria shuo huzi would be
you working to get population voltage
imaging working in a wake behaving mice
so these are mice that are head fixed
below a one photon microscope this is
work
spirited by Kuril again but also while
on saying Seth Benson and sanaya Shroff
from Asher's group and you can see here
traces that look like electrode traces
of their being image of the microscope
from the cortex from the striatum and
from the
a campus and we can see populations of
neurons with this method I think the
previous record that was published so
far is the voltage of two individual
neurons at once here you can see that we
image 8:00 in the awake mouse
hippocampus the traces are shown on the
right and now we are routinely getting
up to a dozen or even more neurons per
field of view and our hope is that this
will get better and better as we refine
our optics and so forth finally because
it's a red light activated it's usually
a red light emitting molecule we can use
it in cont in conjunction with blue
light optogenetics and be able to
activate neurons at the same time as
imaging their voltage so these are three
neurons again awake Mouse upper campus
the blue bars where a mouse is pointing
is when we activate and you can see
multiple the three neurons here imaging
the voltage while we control them at the
same time so summarize we've been
working off the genetic tools for
controlling neurons with light and more
recently to improve our luck we've been
evolving molecules like report on
voltage and the years to come and really
excited about combining these tools why
can't we image the high-speed dynamics
of the brain using new indicators and
new microscopes control the activity
using optogenetic control and then at
the end of the day get molecular and
wiring maps so that we can combine these
datasets into interesting models of how
neural circuits compute so very excited
to see this hopefully it takes shape
over the next decade at least in small
brains hopefully with the knowledge of a
scale up to larger brains quite soon I
think I'll end there and I've mentioned
all the people of lead projects I
believe but let me just enter this slide
which includes many of the people who
collaborate with us and have worked in
lab to make these projects reality thank
you so much
[Applause]
thank you so much yet and I see
questions
coming in absolutely beautiful work my
quick question okay maybe not a quickly
my question is about the discrepancy
between the extremely high resolution
intervention that you're able to do and
these absolutely stunning diagrams that
we see of you know thousands of neurons
connecting to each other my question is
how close are we to combining these two
types of technologies in other words can
we somehow learn the wiring to
sufficient resolution that we can say
now I want to signal this neuron get its
output maybe through light or something
to this next one and then figure out how
our more complex signal somehow
transmitted through multiple neurons
through the brain right so to do that we
have to link the dynamics and the
anatomical pictures together and so
that's actually one of the areas now
that we're working on can we do the
imaging of a given organism and then get
the wiring and molecular composition of
the very same organism and that requires
engineering as well as software in order
to connect those datasets so that's full
but very much a work in progress so
let's uh we'll check it in a year
hopefully one time for one more question
so very beautiful work so in terms of
your expansion is there a physical limit
like how many times you can expend so if
we plumber eyes and expand and form a
second polymer expand again and then we
essentially break the first polymer
which will eventually resist we have
done proof-of-concept expansions that
are three in a row
and these result in enormous expansions
but we have not dilated the resolution
of that yet it's more of just a demo
that we can do it okay thank you so much
[Applause]